on passe maintenant aux miss le test de
culture générale et ridicule oui si le
style c'est d'acheter au programme dont
j'espère que vous le savez mais deux
jours avant l'élection c'est pas être
encore fait ont choisi les douze miss et
pour les choisir et bien le jury choisit
sur trois critères 15 passes et 15
maintenant pardon sur comment se sont
comportés pendant le voyage leur
prestance et puis aussi le test de
culture générale dont elles font un
entretien chacun qui dure 15 minutes à
partir de ces trois de ces trois
critères là on va aller choisir ou non
dans les quinze personnes qui ont cessé
d'être élue miss france donc c'est très
important ce test de culture c'est un
tiers de ce qui va décider de leur
avenir et même pas c'est même la même
image
oui oui parce que généralement tous les
ans on voit des miss qui sont
magnifiques et on dit mais pourquoi ne
sont pas dans les dents dans les
finalistes
et bien tout simplement soit elles ont
foiré leur culture leur test de culture
générale ou alors leur comportement
était la faute en train de dire qu'en
fait tu as vraiment avait fait un super
comportement quand regarder le sujet
puis derrière on va se poser la question
avec tout ajustement à ce qu'il est
utile ou ridicule
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas juste être belle
pour être miss france bah vous pourrez
choisir regardez c'est le 14 décembre
prochain que l'une des trente
prétendants doit succéder à van hamme à
chaves en lui piquant sa couronne pleine
de diamants en échange d'un système à
toutes les foires au boudin de france le
rêve de tout à chacun
mais si ce concours est basée à 98% sur
l'apparence le comité tient aussi à
s'assurer que la tête de ses
prétendantes et bien pleine
et pour ce faire les miss ont passé un
test de culture générale pour évaluer
leurs connaissances de l'histoire mais
aussi de l'actualité un contrôle dont
les pépites ont été dévoilées par sylvie
tellier elle même qui s'en est amusé non
teddy riner n'est pas un chanteur de
r'n'b ni un acteur de cinéma les un
champion de judo vous avez aussi fait
voyager napoléon il a fini sa vie à
sainte hélène et non pas à la réunion ou
à tahiti
quant à marlène schiappa elle n'est pas
encore au panthéon morgane fradon miss
picardie 2010 9 pensent qu'en tel que le
chef pâtissier pierre hermé et
sculpteurs et l'oeuvre le radeau de la
méduse s'appelle en fait le radeau de
bois un petit jeu qui n'a pas beaucoup
amusé et maxime schnyder le délégué
régional miss picardie pour miss france
qui dans la presse a déclaré ça m'agace
que l'on ridiculise ainsi notre miss
picardie quand on n'habite pas à paris
pierre hermé on ne mange pas forcément
ses pâtisseries à la fait preuve de
spontanéité et d'honnêteté
elle n'a pas cherché à masquer là où
elle n'avait pas su répondre avant de
conclure elle s'est placée bien
au-dessus de la moyenne des candidates
alors est-ce que ce test poutre à sa
place sur le podium à miss picardie
réponse le 14 décembre voilà je vous
rappelle que la musique actuelle a
déclaré bien qu'à la femme sont de son
mandat de miss elle avait détesté le
côté un peu femme objet qu'elle avait
subis et qu'il n'avait pas forcément
adorer son règne alors choqué est ce que
pour vous c'est important ridicule le
faire un petit kiff on va commencer par
du ridicule qu'il est bastien pourquoi
est ce que pour toi le test de qi de
culture générale pour être une miss
france c'est ridicule bah je suis censé
sois belle et tais toi
non mais c'est juste un concours de
beauté nom qu'on donne à ne manquent pas
autre chose juste mais si c'est un
concours de beauté on les voit défiler
en maillot de bain habile différentes
manières elles sortent trois phrases
dans la soirée ouais mais on a bon dos
l'ondaine pour le rejoindre ce que tu
crois que les gens quand ils votent se
disent elle l est pas très belles que
bien sûr que sinon mais annonçait sa
tonte absent toute belle changement ça
compte le discours compte énormément me
pendre répétant le disent on vous quelle
est la plus belle
et puis on choisit sur un catalogue on
ne dit jamais pour vous quelle est la
pub et puis la phrase qu'elle sorte ça
ça prouve en rien qu'elle soit
intelligent tu me caser une grande
culture c'est juste qu'elles ont bien
appris une phrase c'est tout ah ben ça
on aura des pépites comme pour ceux
passés tout à l'heure mais après ils
sont peut-être mieux si sessègnon et ou
alors juste encore choqué satam bien
portants luc bien sûr le luc et luc et
magali l'âge alors va coûter du pasquart
à lui importe en lui et c'est absolument
important parce que vous dites tout
temps s'est passé pas à concours de
mannequins c'est pas et livre des loups
que les services français doit parler
doit pas juste défiler sur un podium à
dire bonjour aux gens elle doit aller à
dans une mairie doivent avoir un
scénario en auvergne où ses ailes et en
bourgogne
ça va s'abattre au typage mercredi des
oui non mais faut que la maison de
conversation qu'elle comprenne qu'on lui
dise qu'elle est un minimum
sa culture générale vous pouvez voir
test de qi
elle peut à connaître les trucs être
confirmés après parle évidemment notre
miss france
d'abord ridicules pourquoi c'est au delà
du ridicule jmm c'est complètement con
on peut excuser moi parce que c'est un
concours de beauté c'est factuellement
concours de beauté ya pas une horloge
qui défient et en plus si on va faire un
test de culture générale dans laquelle
faire ça tout les professions à vous au
boucher au médecin
dans un instant on aura les résultats
mais a montré lors enroulé à ses dettes
belle poids et c'est pas moche et de
marais on va donner la réponse après ça
toi dans frantic été miss france qu'elle
a déjà 2007 sadate l'otan mais non mais
alors pourquoi c'est important pour toi
il faut être comme une faute pour être
agent avait bien réussi à moi j'avais
bien réussi ou non mais il faut savoir
que il peut avoir une candidate c'est la
plus belle la plus magnifique ici à la
foire et son test de culture générale
elle ne sera pas présélectionné parce
que toutes les filles qui sont
présélectionnés sont susceptibles d'être
miss france il faut savoir que moi
j'étais pas la plus jolie l'année de
france est raymond chaussée des gens
qu'il aimait parce que j'ai j'ai su me
démarquer par rapport à mon parcours à
mon parcours scolaire à mon discours et
de ce fait le le cul le test de culture
générale mais rachel soient pas évoqués
également enrichi ma chaise 15 côté
plutôt démarquez vous avez du jury je le
comprends mais pour les gens qui votent
ils savent pas trop ce que tu as fait
dans ta vie comment tu te démarques sont
possibles sur tf1 casio percy harvin se
présente on se présente on dit momon
chouikh atmo 1,6 ici et maintenant tu es
toujours dans le but de devenir
coiffeuse et dans les portraits on
invente un cliché juste voir [ __ ]
pedro machado important pour lequel les
clichés mais non on les prend pour des
débuts elles le sont pas on vit avec une
miss france pour la beauté de la semaine
en france et qu'elle qu'elle est pas
bête du tout choisi 12 on va découvrir à
côté mais qu'on ne le pense et moi
départ moi je trouve ça plutôt marrant
je voudrais juste rajouter quelque chose
c'est qu'en fait la société miss france
n'a pas le temps de faire un média
training pour la fille qui va être élu
descombes training bas on apprend
aujourd'hui d'accord dès qu'on est élu
on nous amène dans une salle oise à 30
journalistes une trentaine est là donc
il ya eu la soirée toute l'émotion et
cetera
et là on se retrouve face à ces
journalistes qui nous pose des questions
si on est complètement ben voila si on
n'a aucune heure et violent voilà c'est
fait pour ça ne va pas c'est drôle mais
là où c'est là où je te rejoins c'est
que ne serait ce que vous que vous vous
avoue être très intelligent et brillant
quand vous avez fait une première
émission de télé bas au début les
caméras et où c'était pas évident vous
étiez moins bon qu'aujourd'hui bernois
c'était pour le choc du man on s'est
posé la question pour certaines
personnes de les licencier ou pas
l'instant est évidemment qu'on progresse
cette petite fille elle est là les tout
jeunes elle a 20 ans elle arrive de
province et se retrouve devant tous les
médias
c'est pas évident de dire des choses
intelligentes non la preuve la femme
française que vous adorez les physiques
départ il y avait les nouveaux jeux
j'aime beaucoup l'aube amour que je
demande c'est ben un monde plein de gens
avec des sourires
j'aimerais avoir une baguette magique
répondre le bonheur de partout un
accélérateur de vie je pense que quand
une année de miss france et on serait
pas capable de pouvoir vivre ce qu'on
serait capable de vivre
[Musique]
ajoute avons donné la parole à mathieu
est ce que j'aimerais être que là comme
jean bafoue coûteux tend le micro à la
fin est-ce que tu préparé cette phrase
là ton discours parker moi à l'époque on
n'avait pas le droit de préparer on ne
savait pas la question droit bah en fait
on savait pas la question parce qu'une
question de jours a dit que maintenant
elles ont le droit de préparer la
rentrée n'est qu'avec ta maman dans le
salon un petit peu ou pas du tout bas un
petit peu forcément mais par des frappes
ne m'attendais pas du tout à être très
sélectionnés dont 14 août était tout
content la guerre et la maladie balla
compte
j'étais content mais aimer servir
tondeuse savoir parce que je ne sais pas
ça alors moi je voulais juste dire j'ai
changé d'avis depuis que j'ai vu le
reportage je joue qu'on fasse ce test et
qu'on garde les plus cons parce que
voilà la mise cette année très brillante
rachel aussi et c'est vrai que oui je
reconnais que moi ce qui me choque pas
garder sylvie tellier n'est pas idiote
moi je n'ai jamais dit que les miss
étaient ils me choque c'est juste en leu
leu leu leu leu l'élection elle-même où
je trouve que vraiment c'est montrer des
femmes comme ça et 21 des mecs devant la
télé qui sont là avec leur télécommande
choisissent des fissures dans physique
mais c'est ok
[Rires]
buzek salue un concours vous avez fait
des comtois moi j'ai accompagné
j'adorais fond de teint giron fait le
tour de la france avec elle à tous ces
concours
c'est hyper c'est hyper bien je pose
quelques questions et rapide
dallas qui avait cette année dans le
test pour vous donner une idée qui a
prononcé l'appel du 18 juin 1940
compléter ces difficiles incomplète le
titre de cette peinture à l'huile sur
toile réalisée par théodore géricault
leurs ados 12 au sujet de quelle affaire
célèbre emile zola qui publie son
article j'accuse bref mais s'ils étaient
aussi des questions de football des
questions des questions si la série des
questions ça veut vraiment tous azimuts
il ya 43 question il ya deux ans 37
années je crois c'est pas si évident
fait le chez vous et vous verrez donc
gluck et les amis ça qu'on passe au
moment qu'on aime bien en région me dit
oui on a donc fait faire le test
il ya deux ans il y avait 43 question 15
secondes pour est bon à chaque fois
chacun dans une loge vous pouvez pas
tricher dont 43 question le test il ya
deux ans est bien le premier celui qui a
fait le moins de fautes
bravo c'est le petit bassin
[Applaudissements]
infos sur 43 bravo brown s'est plantée
sur quoi du foot sûrement assez amusant
c'est amusant il s'est juste il sait pas
ce que c'est qu'une fringale sais pas ce
que c'est qu'une seringue à habas mais à
6 et quand c'est quand tout d'un coup on
a faim à tapas bar el tap elle me répond
jean tétreaultville est content dit
souvent le deuxième lot 2 iéna mais
contre toute attente on parle de la
presse people handycam que la presse
people jean gagnant bas le deuxième
pardon c'est encore une personne de la
presse people quatre fautes seulement le
petit luke bravo mais c'est parce que
son souffle lorsque la question
chou-fleur comment je vais perdre mon
écriture des chais pas justement je sais
pas l'écrire banon y avait des aides et
sdxc tout cas c'est pas écrire se dit le
journaliste souffre leur eau ne s'écrit
pas chou fleur aux écrits par des arbres
4 et de supplanter son souffleur vous
verrez c'est pas c'est pas on le spa
légumes que vous aimez beaucoup à la
bravo bravo philippe quatre fautes
seulement sur 43 c'est bien là les
autres commencent à se dire ensuite on
va avancer un petit peu et bien c'est
rachel
rabon ensuite avec six fautes égalité
alors déjà des intellectuels est lésé
séisme l'écrivain gala et bien c'est
vous de bravo avec six fautes directes
l'avant dernier et dernier témoin
mauvais sachant quand même je vous
rassure que même sans passer le test
parce qu'on aurait eu des perles
sachant que bien sûr la gemballa alors
les amis avant dernier avant dernier et
pourtant dieu sait s'il ouvre sa grande
gueule culture et oui tu connais rien
enfants je vais te muter à tout ce que
c'est que ça enfin diouf risquer à cette
faute si le dire et c'est à ton émission
c'est pas celle là celle là c'était si
les données myriam chez les olé
bondé pour alors elle se rassurer pour
te rassurer y avait beaucoup cette année
de questions de sport et on sait que l
adore les vestiaires donc rachat l'adoré
et toi ça me rappelle beaucoup sur les
questions de ses boys à des questions
c'est qu'ils étaient mieux dauphine dans
merci beaucoup